it's decolonizing things that were
placed upon indigenous people in the way
that this dance means that you can use
your body and celebrate who you are how
your spirit wants to move
the idea is that these all of these uh
these spirits are sort of presented in
each person that you're not necessarily
switching from one gender to the next
but you're transcending gender
the who dense represents the
interconnectedness of all people how to
spirits as well as like other folks in
the indigenous community as well as
people just in life of the red the white
the yellow the black no matter who you
are are intertwined and interconnected
not just people but our two-legged our
four-legged our winged are rooted the
Sun the Moon the Stars how we're all
connected together and that at this day
and age that three spirits also have a
space in that
I dance especially for our two-spirit
youth so that they can feel reaffirmed
and that they will have the medicine and
the power to claim who they are and not
hide so when I do these dances it's a
form of a prayer a prayer in motion and
that's something I want to give back to
the world